la información ha sido difundida por el
comisionado que Investiga los
desaparecidos en Ucrania especialmente
en el sector militar él dice que son
siete mil personas del servicio militar
que están desaparecidas se cree que el
60% de ellos están captivos por las
fuerzas de Moscú y el resto de ellos
fallecidos pero su destino causa aún
mayor preocupación no solamente en el
gobierno ucraniano sino en las familias
de estas personas que están
desaparecidas después de oír versiones
como las dadas por dos integrantes ex
integrantes de esas fuerzas
paramilitares que operan básicamente en
el don básico especialmente en esa
batalla por Back mood y también soledad
una pequeña población cerca a bakmuk
donde celebraron intensas batallas en
diciembre y a comienzos de enero estas
dos personas dicen que sus órdenes eran
no tener prisioneros militares
prisioneros incluso les ordenaban
asesinar a muchos de ellos uno de ellos
confiesa haber matado al menos 20 pero
dice que esa era la orden dada por la
comandancia de estas fuerzas Wagner esto
para muchos investigadores que llevan a
cabo toda esta estas investigaciones
sobre los crímenes de guerra en Ucrania
simplemente confirman lo que ellos ya
vienen diciendo desde hace meses sobre
las arbitrariedades los abusos y los
magnicidios que cometen las fuerzas
rusas en Ucrania